bonjour tout le monde comment allez-vous
j'espère que tout le monde va
extrêmement bien
je suis excité là j'étais en train de
cacher ça s'est fait en ce moment je dis
avec beaucoup de trucs sur des gens qui
ont vécu des situations extrêmes et qui
sont sortis là où vous et moi on se
réjouit
dans le genre évidemment en top il ya
les naufragés les mecs qui ont coulé en
bateau et qui s'en sont sortis il ya eu
plein du tarn naufragés aujourd'hui je
vous racontais celle de steven callahan
parce que steven callan quand il était
sur son radeau de sauvetage
il avait pu écrire et il a pris des
notes sur tout ce qu'ils vivaient en
temps réel et en fait ces notes ont été
beaucoup étudié par des psychologues
parce que dans son récit en fait il
parle pas tant de la situation merde
dans laquelle il aimait plus de comment
il le vit et à quel point
psychologiquement c'est dur pour lui
évidemment ne va pas analyser sa
psychologie je vais pas vous lire les
récits de steven mais existe il a sorti
un livre entre temps je vais juste vous
raconter ce qui lui est arrivé et
comment il a survécu tout ce monde
épopée après et c'est incroyable on est
en 1981 les gens dansent ils ont des
coupes de cheveux un peu chelou mais un
peu cool quand même et steven callahan
lui il vient de divorcer un peu relou
alors ici on n'a pas tous vécu un
divorce mais on a tous prendre le monde
j'avais eu une rupture n'est ce pas et
après une rupture il ya plein de
manières de réagir yonex matin la
musculation il y en a ils se mettent à
sortir énormément à aller à plein de
soirée sauf cracovie steven lui il se
dit bon je vais traverser l'atlantique
tous alors c'est pas le premier à
vouloir le faire et c'est pas le premier
qui va le faire d'ailleurs il ya plein
d'humains qui l'ont fait avant lui mais
ça reste quand même une belle petite
épopée traverser l'atlantique et je peux
dire que même si j'ai joué 200 heures
assis au style je ne veux pas tenter de
traverser l'atlantique sol après il faut
savoir que stevens et pas n'importe qui
il a un diplôme universitaire en
philosophie
ce qui n'a aucun rapport le rapport en
revanche c'est qu'après ces études de
philo il a fait d'autres études des
études d'architecte naval ce qui est
beaucoup pour ça c'est l'atlantique il a
prévenu ses proches il donnera pas de
nouvelles pendant au moins trois
semaines et le 26 octobre
c'est le début de la course lebara sont
excités les bateaux partent à vive
allure de l'angleterre et une semaine
plus tard grossi claude sept chats ou
steven du coup il est obligé
d'abandonner la course et de se rabattre
en espagne pour réparer son bien-aimé
bateau quelques semaines plus tard les
réparations sont terminées et steven il
a toujours cet objectif en tête de
traverser l'atlantique
seul c'est une phase de sa vie où il est
un peu paumé il s'est fixé cet objectif
et il a vraiment envie de l'attendre et
pour ça il va d'abord rejoindre les îles
canaries qui seront son dernier stop
avant de définitivement partir pour
traverser l'atlantique le 29 janvier
1982 c'est le jour j c
le grand départ et honnêtement tout se
passe bien pendant sept jours le 4
février il est minuit il est
tranquillement en train de dormir dans
sa couchette mais d'un coup il est
réveillé par un bruit d'explosion
il se réveille en sursaut il en train de
réfléchir à ce qu'il a pu se passer sauf
qu'ils constatent qu'il a les pieds dans
l'eau il ya de l'eau qui est en train de
rentrer dans le bateau à une vitesse
folle
en seulement 30 secondes il a de l'eau
jusqu'à la taille immédiatement il sait
qu'il a peu de temps pour agir ils
seront tout de suite sur le pont du
bateau pour récupérer le radeau de
sauvetage qui est un truc gonflable que
tu lances à l'eau et qui se gonfle tout
seul une fois à l'intérieur il ne reste
plus qu'à couper la corde qui relie le
radeau aux bateaux mais au moment de
faire sa stephen hill à un éclair de
lucidité de malades il se dit mais
attends j'ai que dalle là pour survivre
ok je suis sur un truc qui flotte donc
je vais pas me noyer mais j'ai pas d'eau
pas de bouffe et aucun outil en gros
j'ai survie 24 heures là dessus il
retourne dans son bateau qui est déjà
quasiment entièrement submergées et qui
donc peut couler à tout moment dans le
but de récupérer tout ce qui peut
récupérer et de le mettre sur le radeau
de survie sauf que les gars aient fait
nuit et le bateau il est rempli d'eau le
mec il est plongé dans le noir en apnée
en train de toucher plein de trucs
autour de lui et de récupérer des choses
à la vague parmi ces choses se trouve un
kit de survie
il réussit une nouvelle voie à
s'extirper du bateau et à rejoindre son
radeau de survie
là on va pas se mentir steven il passe
une nuit très moyenne il est dans son
radeau et surtout il est pris dans une
tempête c'est à dire qu'en termes de
confort on est aux abysses puisque terme
et dans tous les sens et était dans le
match surtout tu as peur que leur ado se
retourne et qui coule
heureusement le radeau tient le coup et
le lendemain matin le jour se lève et
c'est la première matinée de son périple
à son réveil steven y faire un petit
bilan
il n'a rien avec lui qui lui permettent
de prendre contact avec la terre ferme
pas de portable évidemment pas de radio
rien ensuite ils estiment être à environ
1000 km des côtes et à 500 km à l'est de
la voie de navigation la plus proche
emprunté par plein de navires de
commerce
heureusement le vent souffle vers
l'ouest du coup il estime qu'il nous
faudra environ deux semaines pour
atteindre cette fameuse voie de
navigation mais dans son kit de survie
il ya de l'eau et de la nourriture pour
huit jours la stat est ouf
mais en fait on peut survivre plusieurs
dizaines de jours sans manger
en revanche on peut survivre que trois
jours sans boire c'est terrible d'être
déshydraté en mer évidemment pas ce que
tu as envie de boire l'eau de mer c'est
la pire chose à faire puisqu'elle
contient du sel et que le celte
déshydrate beaucoup plus que l'eau
piedra steven le sait son objectif c'est
donc de trouver un moyen d'obtenir de
l'eau potable
mais bonne surprise en ouvrant son kit
de survie et tombe sur trois quitte de
filtration d'eau par rayonnement solaire
c'est un mot qui fait peur mais en gros
c'est assez simple c'est juste une bouée
que tu gonfles dans laquelle tu met de
l'eau de mer et le soleil en tapant sur
la boulette va faire que l'eau s'évapore
et donc se sépare du sel qu'elle
contenait mais petit problème en fait
c'est kit de filtration d'eau ils ont
été créés pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale en gros c'était un truc que
yahvé sur les navires de guerre et quand
un navire se retrouver à couler être
dans la mer bas les gens pouvaient
survivre grâce à ces radeaux de
sauvetage et à ces kits de survie par
conséquent leur utilisation elle est
absolument pas intuitive
stephen hill légaux filière rempli d'eau
de mer il attend quelques heures mais
look ça donne les papes au tabac est
toujours sales et comme ils n'arrivent
pas à faire fonctionner l'équipe il va
avoir une autre idée pour savoir que
quand tu es au milieu de la mer comme ça
il pleut assez régulièrement
du coup il va essayer la stratégie de
récolter l'eau de pluie pour la boire
parce que le plu est potable mais en
l'écoutant
il s'aperçoit qu'elles sont absolument
ignobles le goût parce qu'en fait elles
ont été contaminées par les pigments
orange de la peinture du radeau de
sauvetage c'est terrible tu dois
tellement vouloir aux mecs compare le
truc on est au septième jour du périple
de steven il lui reste plus qu'un jour
de provisions du coup ça devient très
urgent pour lui de trouver un moyen de
fabriquer de l'eau potable
il va faire un move très bowles il va
prendre le couteau que contient le kit
de survie et il va défoncer l'un des
trois kits de filtration d'eau dans le
but de démanteler et d'essayer de
comprendre son fonctionnement
et devinez quoi il comprend le
fonctionnement du truc en tout cas jours
de fête
il a maintenant de quoi avoir de l'eau
potable tous les jours alors attention
on ne parle pas d'une bouteille d'un
litre à vis de 5 tous les jours et
grapille quelques cuillères à soupe mais
ça lui permet de rester en vie et il
fait face aussi un autre problème c'est
que il est constamment au soleil au
milieu de l'océan
et il est dans un environnement qui est
très très très salée et le mélange des
deux ça crée des croûtes sur tout son
corps tes potes petites croûtes qui le
graet et qu'ils font mal ça voilà c'est
un petit bonus du périple bien relou
pour lui jours aux deux bonnes nouvelles
la première c'est qu'en onze jours sous
son radeau il ya un véritable petit
écosystème qui s'est formée et la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est qu'avant
de quitter son bateau il a réussi à
prendre en plus du kit de survie un
fusil harpon pendant toute une journée
il va essayer de tirer sur les poissons
qu'ils fassent atp dur à dos mais ils
n'arrivent pas à les avoir
ah oui la vie c'est pas un jeu vidéo du
coup ils continuent d'essayer de choper
des poissons mais cette fois c'est avec
le harpon dans la main mais bingo après
plusieurs heures il prend le coup de
main et il arrive enfin à choper
quelques poissons
malgré ça il prend très cher
physiquement en seulement 11 jours il a
perdu plus de 20 kilos c'est à dire que
vraiment les doses d'eau et de
nourriture dont se parle c'est dérisoire
c'est juste le
minimum requis pour rester en vie jour
14 steven est en train de dormir dans
son radeau faut savoir que quand il dort
c'est plusieurs petites pièces d'une
heure une heure et demie s'est jamais
une belle nuit de six sept huit neuf
heures comme donc fait pendant sept
heures et demie de sommeil il se fait
réveiller parce qu'il ya un truc qui
tape son radeau et ce truc c'est pas un
plongeur qui a remonté à la surface
après avoir trouver des trésors
c'est un requin du bruit pour l'eurocup
alors faut savoir que cette idée reçue
du les requins y voit les humains ils
rôdent autour pour les manger c'est faux
les requins il voit très très mal et la
plupart du temps quand il attaque un
humain ils ont même pas vu que c'était
un humain et le requinquer là au tour de
steven il est pas là pour stephen il est
là pour chasser les poissons qui rôdent
autour de son radeau grâce à l'éco
système qui est en dessous le souci
c'est qu'en chassant les poissons les
requins des fois ils tapent dans le
radeau et steven il a peur que ça en
dommages le radeau et que leur ado cool
auquel cas shipshaw steven du coup
pendant plusieurs heures il ya un v1
engagé entre steven et le requin et
steven avec l'aide du harpon va réussir
à blesser le requin qui va enfin lâché
la faire et là miracle
quelques minutes après la fin de cette
bataille steven aperçoit au loin un
bateau plus précisément un navire de
commerce et la lumière des flers du kit
de survie et le secoue dans tous les
sens et rien à l'horizon à part lui il
est convaincu que le bateau le voit le
bateau se rapprochent ils se rapprochent
tellement que steven raconte qu'à ce
moment là il se souvient de l'odeur de
l'essence et de l'effet incroyable que
ça lui a fait et puis le bateau continue
de se rapprocher plus d'un coup ils
s'éloignent s'éloigne parce qu'en fait
le bateau n'a pas vu steven il a juste
continuer sa route passant pas trop loin
de steven mais sans leur père ait pour
autant
steven elle est littéralement en pls et
il se dit comment je vais faire jour 28
après le premier bateau dont on vient de
parler il en a vu d'autres à qui il a
fait des signes devant lesquels il a
remué des flames
mais aucun ne la psychologie comment il
est anéanti puisque cette route c'est sa
seule chance d'être secourue et comprend
qu'il est vraiment dans la merde que
c'est pas parce qu'il atteint à un
endroit où il ya des bateaux qui va être
sauvé pour autant et surtout ils
commencent à souffrir fortement de
déshydratation de manque de nourriture
de sa solitude du danger qu'ils
encourent psychologiquement il est
vraiment mis à rude épreuve jour 43
jours de pêche pour stephen mais cette
fois il se passe une couille empêchant
et plantes sont à pompe dans un poisson
et le poisson en remuant dans tous les
sens cass l'epic
arbon qui restent plantés en lui et
après ça le poisson se réfugient sous
leurs ados et le pic planté dans le
poisson transperce l'un des flotteurs du
radeau vous pensiez être malchanceux à
côté steven vous êtes tellement chanceux
le flotteur ce vide totalement de son
erp steven il essaie de contenir l'air
dedans mais il peut rien faire mais le
radeau coule pas pour autant sous un
radeau tu as plusieurs flotteur en
revanche le fait que ce flotteur la soie
à sec ça rend le radeau de steven hyper
instable tellement instable que ça
devient vraiment dangereux pour steven
de se pencher ordures à dos comme il le
fait habituellement pour pêcher et
récupérer l'autre ces kits de filtration
les 7 jours qui suivent les journées de
seven elles sont rythmées par la
tentative de réparation de ce de
flotteurs et ce véritable crack en
fouillant dans son kit de survie tombe
sur une fourchette et grâce à cette
fourchette
il réussit à fixer la fuite du flotteur
ne me demandez pas comment j'en ai pas
la moindre idée moi les fourchettes je
mange avec c'est toujours 66 ça fait
maintenant plus de deux mois que steven
dérive seul sur son radeau de survie et
qu'il espère désespérément croiser la
route de quelqu'un ce jour là il ya une
mauvaise nouvelle de taille le requin un
côté une blague
le flotteur on s'amuse c'est drôle ces
filtres à eau sont périmés
malheureusement le mélange du soleil et
du sel à en deux mois complètement
bousillé le tissu que contiennent les
filtres et c'est juste irréparable
steven il lui reste les trois concertos
de son kit de survie qui s'est promis de
boire que quand il aurait pas d'autre
choix
et après c'est chao jour 76 steven est à
bout de force ce jour là steven il se
réveille et autour du radeau ils tombent
sur des bouteilles en plastique et c'est
bien la seule fois de sa vie où il a été
ravi de voir des bouteilles en plastique
dans l'océan puisque ça veut dire qu'il
ya de la vie humaine pas loin d'ici et
en levant les yeux steven voix d'élus
avant mon pote il voit une île avec
plein d'armes il n'a pas vu de
végétation depuis deux mois et l'ice dit
ça tombe à pic
j'allais crever là mais en s'approchant
de l'île steven il comprend que cette
île il n'y a pas d'arbres comme il a cru
voir au loin
c'est toute petite île avec plein de
falaise et avec tout autour des cailloux
dans l'eau et des coraux très coupants
sauf que steven est lui complètement à
sec et il n'a pas d'autre choix que de
tenter d'aller sur cette île pour
trouver de l'eau il sait qu'il ya très
peu de chances qu'ils réussissent parce
que les courants vont fracasser contre
les cailloux qui entoure l'île mais il
n'a pas le choix que ça se finisse bien
ou mal je dois aller sur cette île et à
ce même moment ils entendaient qui en
tournant la tête
il voit une petite barque qui contient
deux pêcheurs s'approcher de lui et lui
dire il ya quelqu'un est-ce que tout va
bien et c'est à ce moment là et pas
avant que oui pour stephen tout allait
bien surtout quelques minutes plus tard
quand les pêcheurs l'ont ramené sur
l'île et qu'il a enfin pu après 76 jours
remettent un pied à terre
messieurs dames c'est la fin de cette
vidéo de cette histoire j'espère qu'elle
vous a plu je trouve ça vraiment
incroyable ces forces de la nature qui
sont capables de survivre en comptant
juste sur eux-mêmes et rien d'autre sur
leur capacité à réfléchir à analyser
steven a raconté son histoire dans un
livre qu'il a sorti en 92 je croyais qu
est resté dans les best seller aux états
unis 35 semaines d'affilée il a aussi
fait beaucoup de conférences pour
raconter son histoire et tout et c'est
vraiment incroyable ya pas mal de gens
qui ont vécu des trucs similaires il y
en a aussi beaucoup qu'on vécu ça et
dont l'issue a n'a pas été aussi
chanceuse donc voilà je trouve son
histoire hyper touchante et je trouve
qu'il a vachement gérer c'est
impressionnant j'avais raconté une même
vidéo dans le genre avec ceux qui
avaient survécu à des crashs d'avion et
c'était vachement impressionnant après
vous savez moi je suis vraiment ça me
fait vachement facilement peur le milieu
aquatique la mer l'océan c'est tellement
vaste c'est tellement grand donc
forcément ça m'a touché à bientôt non
moi c'est pas trop vous avez regardé
cette vidéo sur la terre ferme
tout va bien bref a très vite les squido
sportez vous bien
je
[Musique]